im nordrhein westfälischen schwerte ist
dieser grünstreifen an einer
hauptverkehrsstraße radikal gerodet
worden nach 170 bäume und sträucher
wurden einfach dem erdboden gleich
gemacht wo bisher lärm und sichtschutz
durch dichtes grün war ist nur noch
blanker beton zu sehen
verantwortlich für den kahlschlag ist
der landesbetrieb straßen nrw
die anwohner sind stinksauer eine
frechheit ist also gar nicht im ersten
moment wussten ja gar nicht was los ist
und innerhalb von wenigen stunden war
alles kahl sagt mal das ganze ist
eigentlich indiskutabel ende 2020
schafft der landesbetrieb straßen.nrw
tatsachen und macht die bis zu 70 jahre
alten bäume einfach platt dabei hat das
land mit den bäumen gar nichts zu tun
denn sie gehören der stadt schwerte im
rathaus wurde niemand informiert der
entstandene schaden ist immens
wer gehört wert ermittelt worden durch
einen öffentlichen gutachter und der
befindet sich im unteren sechsstelligen
betrag und der ökologische wert ist auch
durch die gutachter noch mal bestimmt
worden und da wurde ihm gesagt ja ich
hatte einen sehr sehr hohen ökologischen
wert an der stelle
die bäume waren fast alle gesund und
standen nicht nur auf städtischen grund
auch auf privatgrundstücken der anwohner
hat die behörde tabula rasa gemacht
das heißt sie sollen ja aufforsten wie
sollen wir nicht mit 20 titeln ankommt
ich finde richtiger bäume sehen und habe
den schaden nicht erzeugt die haben ihn
erzeugt also sollen sie fit machen
ganz einfach wenige tage nach dem
kahlschlag rollen straßen in der weg
gegenüber anwohnern den fehler noch ein
auf anfrage des länderspiels heißt es
nur noch der landesbetrieb straßenbau
nordrhein-westfalen prüft aktuell die
rechtslage die rechtliche situation
hätte man wohl besser geprüft bevor man
die bäume umgehauen hat
natürlich sieht jetzt auch traurig aus
es ist immer schöner in grüne bäume zu
gucken als auf triste graue gasen dich
jetzt hoffen wir einfach dass sind auch
natürlich auch wieder schnell aufforsten
aber bis die bäume wieder so groß sind
was angesagt 60 70 jahre
dann sind wir nicht mehr hier die stadt
und die anwohner erwarten dass der alte
zustand schnellstens wieder hergestellt
wird und straßen nrw den kompletten
grünstreifen wieder aufforstet ansonsten
will die stadt vor gericht ziehen und
schadensersatz fordern